[Music]
this isn't such a topic of conversation
to those happy weekends producers come
because they really want to make sure
you're not leaving the house because you
have to hide in there's and there with
their there three days they're in a
house with really tall bushes everywhere
so people can't see him
they just load up the house with like
your favorite wines food everything you
just make grocery lists and you
basically just spend like serious
quality time for three days Wow and
producers come and go as they please
just to make sure you're always there
okay so do you have a phone I mean you
look at what you do yeah and how did
they go about keeping it secret like are
you in like the black SUV to get you
shut up we are black SUVs you're under
alias names so Shawn was Eric and I was
Ariel from the Limerick mermaid they
don't put his name under that as flight
on flights and when like he'd come down
from both of us came down from getting
off the plane the driver would be
signing there with signs that said
either Ariel or Eric and we obviously
I'd apply in different days yeah any
other security measures you can think of
this is so interests I know it I love
this kind of stuff because it's like you
that's the stuff people don't know
totally um I think I'm pretty sure like
I wanted to get spray tans while I was
there and I think they made like the
spray tan people will sign contracts
right like NDA's never yeah
you